[Music]  The Voice winner Jordan Smith is engaged  the 22 year old singer is truly winning  in 2016  Smith popped the question to his  girlfriend christened any Friday at the  Boston Public Garden and she said yes  the newly engaged couple shared the  exciting news on social media captioning  the cute moment ringing in the New Year  with my future wife hashtag mr. and mrs.  Smith Smith's fiance couldn't wait to  show off her sparkler posting the same  pic on her Facebook and writing  2016 you're definitely my favorite as if  2015 wasn't already a good year for  Smith taking home first place on season  nine of the voice Jordan struck he has a  lot to look forward to in 2016  especially spending forever with his  bride-to-be or as Smith called her the  love of my life